HI THERE YOUTUBE.
MY NAME'S JOHN GREEN.
I'M ONE HALF
OF THE VLOGBROTHERS
ALONG WITH MY BROTHER, HANK.
- HI, I'M HANK.
HANK AND I LIVE ON OPPOSITE SIDES OF THE COUNTRY.
NOW THAT YOUTUBE
COMES IN WIDESCREEN,
I CAN SHOW YOU
APPROXIMATELY WHERE WE LIVE.
HANK LIVES HERE,
(points)
AND I LIVE HERE.
DESPITE LIVING ON OPPOSITE
SIDES OF THE COUNTRY,
OUR OFFICES LOOK
REALLY, REALLY SIMILAR.
WHICH I NEVER NOTICED
BEFORE.
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS,
JOHN AND I HAVE BEEN
BRIDGING THAT DISTANCE
BY COMMUNICATING THROUGH
VIDEO BLOGS
ON YOUTUBE.
BUT THIS PROJECT
HASN'T BEEN JUST ABOUT US
FOR A
LONG TIME NOW.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO INTRODUCE SOME OF OUR FAVORITE VIDEOS
FROM THE
2008 PROJECT FOR AWESOME,
AN ANNUAL EVENT
IN THE HOLIDAY SEASON,
WHEN TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF YOUTUBERS COME TOGETHER
TO BRING ATTENTION
TO CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THE
PROJECT FOR AWESOME IS NOT ONLY
THAT IT REMINDS US THAT
THE TRUE SPIRIT OF THIS SEASON
IS GIVING,
BUT ALSO THAT IT ALLOWS ME
TO QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY DEAL WITH ALL MY PRESENT-BUYING.
FOR INSTANCE,
ONE OF THE VIDEOS THAT WE'RE
FEATURING TODAY
IS HEIFER INTERNATIONAL,
AN ORGANIZATION
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE LIKE ME
TO BUY ANIMALS FOR PEOPLE
LIKE MY BROTHER, HANK.
AWESOME.
I WOULD LIKE A PLATYPUS.
OR MAYBE A LIGER!
A LIGER WOULD BE AMAZING.
WELL ACTUALLY, I'M NOT BUYING AN ANIMAL "FOR YOU",
I'M BUYING AN ANIMAL
"FOR" YOU,
THAT GOES
TO SOMEONE WHO NEEDS IT.
YEAH O-O-OKAY!
I-
I KINDA HAD MY HEART
SET ON THE LIGER,
(disappointed)
BUT UH, THIS IS GOOD TOO.
AND THE COOLEST PART
IS YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO BUY
A FULL ANIMAL.
YOU CAN BUY A PARTICULAR PART
OF AN ANIMAL.
FOR INSTANCE, HANK,
THIS YEAR FOR CHRISTMAS,
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
IN ADVANCE
THAT I GOT YOU
FIVE LLAMA BUTTS.
NOW, ADMITTEDLY, FOR
THE PRICE OF FIVE LLAMA BUTTS
I COULD HAVE
GOTTEN YOU A LLAMA,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT
TO GET YOU A LLAMA.
I WANTED YOU TO GET
A LOT OF LLAMA BUTT.
(shocked gasp)
ANYWAY,
YOUTUBE WAS EXTREMELY,
EXTREMELY, EXTREMELY, EXTREMELY KIND THIS YEAR
TO ALLOW US TO BECOME
GUEST EDITORS OF THE FRONT PAGE
FOR A DAY.
SO WE'VE TAKEN THIS RESPONSIBILITY EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY,
WE HAVEN'T PUT ANY
OF OUR OWN VIDEOS UP,
LIKE OPRAH DID
THAT ONE TIME,
AND WE HAVEN'T JUST CHOSEN
OUR BEST FRIENDS.
THOUGH,
OUR PARENTS MADE A VIDEO,
AND I... UH,
WE INCLUDED THAT ONE.
I MEAN, THEY'RE OUR PARENTS.
WE OWE THEM. A LOT.
BUT REST ASSURED, THE DECISION WAS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT!
AND I FEEL VERY GUILTY
ABOUT NOT PUTTING
SOME OF THE REALLY AMAZING
PROJECT FOR AWESOME VIDEOS
ON THE FRONT PAGE THAT
I COULDN'T.
SO YOU SHOULD PROBABLY
JUST SEARCH AROUND
FOR PROJECT FOR AWESOME VIDEOS
BECAUSE THERE ARE "LOTS"
THAT ARE REALLY AMAZING
THAT DIDN'T GET FEATURED
ON THE
FRONT PAGE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO WE KNOW AS
"NERDFIGHTERS",
WHO HELPED MAKE THIS
PROJECT SUCH A SUCCESS.
AND I WANT TO SAY
THANKS TO EVERYONE
WHO'S WATCHING THIS
INSIDE THIS BOX
FOR WATCHING A VIDEO
THAT'S NOT ABOUT
TURKISH, SOCCER,
OR WATER-SKIING SQUIRRELS.
BUT MOST OF ALL,
WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR CHECKING OUT
THE PROJECT FOR AWESOME
VIDEOS
AND FOR CONSIDERING GIVING
YOUR TIME AND MONEY
TO PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS
WHO DO THINGS BECAUSE
THEY'RE JUST
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
THIS IS HANK GREEN
FOR THE VLOGBROTHERS.
DON'T FORGET
TO BE AWESOME.
Closed Captioning
provided by CaptionThis
CaptionMyVideo@live.com